[Music]
welcome back
a tennessee man convicted for the 2007
kidnappings rapes and murders of a young
couple is seeking an appeal
eric boyd was sentenced to spend the
rest of his life in prison but his
attorney says
he was wrongfully accused the way how
she was positioned
and the way how she was tied to me
was telling that that she was alive and
suffocated in the
trash can the death of 21 year old
shannon christian was long and torturous
the medical examiner says christian was
beaten and raped then trapped inside a
trash can
her boyfriend 23-year-old christopher
newsom was also raped before he was shot
three times in his head
then lit on fire the fire now is
superimposed
on everything on all the gunshot wounds
and also if
one is alive during fire then the
inhaled and
suit and and and all the fumes from the
fire
are going to be deposited on the airway
and there was none of that
the couple was heading out on a date on
january 6 2007
when they were carjacked in front of
their apartment four people were
arrested and charged with their
kidnappings
rapes and murders a fifth eric boyd was
convicted of carjacking
but in 2018 boyd was indicted on 36
charges
including murder after co-defendant
george thomas agreed to testify against
him
prosecutors offered thomas a reduced
sentence from life in prison to 50 years
when you saw the three flashes
who did you see calling mr newsome mr
board
and where did he pull mr newsome
directly
before me and to the back of the
building
what happened after he uh pulled mr
newsome to that location
they came back and grabbed the can of
gas
who did that missed the board a jury
found 47 year old eric boyd
guilty on all counts and he was given
two life sentences
now boyd is appealing saying thomas's
testimony is uncorroborated and that the
jury pool was tainted
due to media coverage it is our position
that
the evidence is insufficient because mr
thomas was a co-defendant he was an
accomplice
and the well-known rule is that you
cannot convict
a person based solely upon the
uncorroborated testimony of a of a
co-defendant or an accomplice
but prosecutors say the medical evidence
and testimony of other witnesses
corroborates thomas story ms mathis's
testimony
from federal court that she loaned the
defendant her wife tonya
weakened the offenses corroborated
thomas's testimony
and xavier jenkins testimony that he saw
mathis's pontiac but she identified in a
photographic lineup
parked behind miss christian's
forerunner at the residence on the night
of the defense
also corroborated george thomas's
testimony
let's bring in bernard and terry one
last time to discuss bernardo the
prosecutor who
actually graduated from law school with
me laid out uh
why the testament was corroborated by
the co-defendant was that persuasive to
you
yes it was definitely persuasive you
know that when it comes to putting up a
person that is a co-defendant someone
else who played a part in the crime
itself
that the court and jurors look down upon
this type of testimony that's why it's
so important
that there's corroborating factors
corroborating evidence to actually
corroborate
what this person is saying and there was
more than enough corroborating factors
such as the entire testimony of the
medical examiner
as well as the other ladies that also
took part in this incident
now terry i noticed that the judges had
few questions for the prosecutor
and the defense who said they wanted
five minutes for rebuttal actually
gave it up at the end is that a sign
that we should be seeing one side might
be winning this appeal over the other
no question about that brian you never
want to give up
an opportunity to argue on behalf of
your client i think
clearly in this case the defense was
thinking to himself that he had a losing
argument
you heard him there talk about it was
insufficient evidence because the
co-defendant was
the only cooperating evidence and
bernard mentioned no that wasn't the
only evidence and in fact the judge
asked him even if it had been that would
have been okay the case law supports
that
and in fact we didn't even hear a
response
from the defense attorney at that point
he said to himself
well okay judge yeah i guess maybe
you're right so he
clearly was either not arguing well on
behalf of his client
or he just you know didn't do his
research but
clearly giving up that rebuttal argument
he gave up and
basically i think didn't do a great job
arguing on behalf of his client
now bernardo one issue came up that's
interesting it's very similar to new
york the exhaustion rule
when it comes to picking a jury that
seems to be an issue here because the
defense had more um preamps to kind of
get out some of the jurors could that be
an issue that hurts the defense here
no i don't think it's an issue that's
going to hurt the defense because in the
end the
court is going to determine based on
looking at all the facts and all the
evidence that was presented in the case
was it harmless error was that an error
that could have changed the outcome of
the case
all right thank you both and thank you
for joining us here we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice
in america